bella a tutti ragazzi tradizione lo
cominciò così questo video perché oggi
fa vj tv compie cinque anni su youtube
soltanto checkin argia compiti 10 e
oltre però cinque anni se uno ci pensa
soltanto e ci vorrebbero musica
strappalacrime in questo momento
detto questo non voglio soffermarmi sui
discorsi strappalacrime o robe del
genere anche perché l'otto dicembre è un
vero e proprio compleanno come ripeto
ogni anno ma lo sapete già tutti l'otto
dicembre state a casa non per la festa
dell'immacolata ma perché è nato fuori
gtv e di conseguenza volevo fare un
video un po particolare ho paura di
farlo ma lo faccio lo stesso quando ho
iniziato a fare video su youtube
utilizzava il mio computer vecchio
l'altro giorno sono tornato a casa mia a
torino e ho acceso il vecchio computer
quello che utilizzavo all'inizio per
fare video ho trovato delle cartelle
piene di roba vecchia e allora cosa ha
fatto ho preso un hard disk o infilato
dentro l'hard disk tutte le cose vecchie
del mio computer ci sono più segreti
dentro il mio vecchio computer che
dentro l'area 51 ragazzi li ho tutti qua
dentro
raga sarà un viaggio indietro nel tempo
questa cosa ragazzi questa ma grazie a
dio rosa italiano anche come stavi mezzo
gesù mamma mia che qualità video
tutorial come farsi i capelli alla fa
piacere
poi c'è una cartella piena zeppa di foto
che abbiamo tipo pure a te perché mi ero
scritto pure a te sulle dita quali
problemi questo era un piccione dentro
la scuola
non so perché stavo facendo queste foto
dio mio a ovest a una foto di mitico il
suo gatto un'altra foto rini che col suo
gatto mamma cerca di te ma per come me
se diventa così deficiente nella vita
per facciamo queste cose ma ma cosa
aveva ma se spremi coi capelli esce
l'olio extravergine veni chi era già
mastrolindo ai tempi ma mille volte
meglio da ma nessuno mi mi diceva allora
questa non me lo vorrei far vedere ma ve
la faccio vedere per farvi capire il
disagio mi ero messo scrivere con il
gesso sul banco e ho scritto questa cosa
questa un mio amico
tralasciando il mio amico scemo a questi
legge meglio non vedo l'ora che possono
questa settimana ho bisogno di stare con
te il più tempo possibile perché 80 anni
non basteranno ti amo orsacchiotto
avete presente la reazione che ho avuto
in barbie nel video di barbie barbie
zuccherino mia attenzione qua abbiamo un
video paura sembra già dopo mero ho
paura che però clicchiamo bene ma è
bugia più vera fu detta hanno forse si
pensò bene stai d'addio zio bijoux se vi
perdete nelle paludi del nebraska e non
sapete come nutrirli quest'oggi bear
fari chris mi insegnerà come nutrire gli
animali locali della zona
questo è un animale pericolosissimo
comunemente chiamato tritone e oggi fa
vj vi insegnerà come catturarlo fare
veloci ho preso sul serio scacchi ma non
preso davvero come possono lasciare
fenomeno ma l'importante è che siate voi
i padroni della natura il tritone ha dei
capelli più belli nei tuoi comunque non
so se ai vini notato avete imparato come
catturare un territorio ma è comunque
nel caso lo stesse chiedendo no non l'ho
mangiato grazie dio ha detto
ma secondo me avevo dei problemi anche
adesso è però una volta ancora di più
o mio dio o mio dio quanto vecchia st
foto 3 novembre del 2003 che dici ma ad
ora che fiero bach e fiero a firenze
chesta fatto play secolare ragas non
fanno male i capelli non si vedono a
firenze avevo fatto sta foto qua è udite
udite abbiamo il mio esame di maturità
voi vi metterete a ridere pensando che
cosa sto vedendo quello sei tu nei video
si io nel mio esame di maturità ho
portato questo e mi ha promosso storia
del video e ho portato la storia del
video come stamani maturità no cioè io
ho preso questo screenshot di out
l'astensione screenshot di qualità e per
l'esame di maturità anzi sa mai
è come se non bastasse sempre argomento
scuola tanto per chiudere avevo le medie
dei miei voti alla scritto ora
ripartiamo dal primo italiano 56 scritto
ora alle cinque e mezzo aveva una
prospera un pò [ __ ] è però storia set
e mezzo 6 considerando che la stessa
proprio italiano era un po gioca in
durante italiano latte storia era un po
meno gioco inglese 6 e 7 più matematica
3 con la faccina triste vero simpatico
darvi un quello informatica 5 più
scritto niente statistica 7 meno 7 meno
sistemi 5 orale niente elettronica 22 ma
mia madre in periodo natalizio ci ha
sempre avuto questa cosa di regalarmi un
pandorino piccolo ogni anno puntualmente
me lo prende e io aspetto il giorno di
natale per mangiar melo è una cosa molto
dolce grazie mamma primo anno che ho
aperto il canale tenevo questo widget
sul telefono che mi contava gli iscritti
in tempo reale le rotte nei voli hotel e
accendere un telefono che devo pam però
gli iscritti quanti ne avevo fatti in
quel giorno ero ossessionato da quella
roba lì pena certa storia stati talmente
tanti che noi ce vò che a contarli ho
detto non cincischi nova da vada va bè
ragazzi c'è da dire che possiamo
concludere quel video è stato un bel
tuffo nel passato era meglio non farlo
per certi punti di vista però vabbè però
vi sia piaciuto ragazzi io sono
contentissimo di aver passato questi
cinque anni con voi spero che voi vi
siate divertiti in questi cinque anni io
spero di riuscire a divertirvi ancora
per altri 5
altri 50 e importante che mi casca la
barba prima o poi quel momento mi piace
anche la lista circoscrizione saresti
schiette e noi ci rivediamo anno
prossimo vinto da ragazzo il telecomando
cinque anni è un brevi
[Musica]